Okay.
So there's this,
there's this spirit of good,
let's say,
and what the spirit of good does is act
in the world on the potential of the
world to generate the actuality of the
world.
And the Judeo Christian proposition is,
is that if you confront the potential of
the world with good in mind,
using truth,
truthful communication,
then the order that you extract is good.
And then that's echoed in genesis when
God is using the word and he creates
cosmos out of potential.
And every time he does that,
he says,
and it was good.
Which is,
I think it's so interesting because
there's a proposition there and the
proposition there is that if you
encounter potential with truth,
the cosmos you create is actually good.
Well,
that's,
that's just an absolutely overwhelming
idea.
It's like if it's true,
and if it's true,
it's the greatest idea there ever was.